Salut les mentalos avec un "O" !
J'ai regardé depuis 2 jours, passer dans les tendances de Youtube, 2 vidéo: une de Squeezie, une de Amixem, qui parlent des top commentaires.
Et la question c'est, pourquoi on veut être en top commentaire ?
Je vais vous le dire, c'est pour les endorphines !
Générique !
[musique]
C'est vraiment en voyant passer ces vidéos que je me suis dit mais pourquoi les gens veulent être en top commentaires.
Et en fait je sais pourquoi, c'est vraiment pour la molécule du bonheur, les endorphines.
C'est une molécule qu'on dégage en faisant du sport, en mangeant du chocolat en ayant un orgasme.
C'est une gratification naturelle que nous donne notre cerveau pour nous droguer et pour nous rendre heureux.
Vous connaissez forcément ce moment où ça fait: "Ah trop bien !"
[rires]
Et ce n'était pas l'orgasme que je faisais ok ?!
Mais on reçoit aussi cette molécule quand on fait quelque chose de compliqué, quand on atteint un objectif.
C'est un stimulant aussi d'aller vouloir la chercher. C'est pour ça que le cerveau la secrète, c'est pour nous stimuler à aller chercher cette molécule.
Et en 2014, et même les quelques années qui ont suivi, il y a eu plusieurs études intéressantes à ce sujet en rapport avec les réseaux sociaux. Quel est notre rapport aux réseaux sociaux.
Et bien parfois, rien que le fait de voir qu'on a une nouvelle notification, peut déclencher ça.
Et quand on voit que le nombre de like augmente sur Facebook, alors là c'est l'euphorie dans notre tête, c'est le carnaval, c'est la grande droguerie !
"Ah ouais Fabien une étude ? Mais elles viennent d'où tes sources ?" [imite les abonnés]
Mais j'ai mes sources mais en fait je ne vais pas rentrer dans ce système de tous les youtubeurs qui justifient par des sources Internet.
Déjà parce que les sources ce n'est pas que Internet, c'est des bouquins, c'est des expériences, c'est des conférences, des formations.
Que d'une manière assez drôle quand moi je donne une formation et qu'on utilise ce que j'ai dit en formation comme source, on ne m'a pas demandé à ce moment là ma source quand j'ai fait la formation. Enfin, c'est assez drôle.
Principalement les sources de ce que je ne connaissais pas de ce que je suis en train de vous dire, elles viennent de l'OSU.
C'est Ohio States University.
Ils ont un site internet, vous pouvez aller consulter toutes les études à loisir, sur new.osu.edu
En tout cas ça explique cette envie d’être en top commentaire, dans les commentaires YouTube.
Pour être tout en haut, parce que quand on est top commentaire, forcément il y a une gratification et il y a un sentiment qui un petit peu lié à l’égo , qui est un autre comportement social,
qui vient de la comparaison avec l'autre sur les réseaux sociaux, chose qu'on avait à la base dans le naturel mais qui a été amplifié par les réseaux sociaux.
Et qui fait que ah on a du bonheur.
Mais c'est très éphémère en plus, c'est quelques instants.
Et là vous vous dites: "Mais oui, mais vous les youtubeurs vous demandez toujours aussi des pouces !"
Oui...
C'est vrai.
Moi le premier, je le rappelle à chaque fins de vidéos.
Déjà parce que là c'est une étude de YouTube qui montre que si on ne rappelle pas l’engagement, alors dans ces cas là, les gens n'y pensent pas forcément.
La grande majorité silencieuse, celle qu'on appelle la majorité silencieuse, même si elle a aimé, elle ne va pas liker.
Alors que quelqu'un qui n'a pas aimé, va forcément penser à disliker. Ça il n'y a pas de problème.
C'est aussi le principe du bon restaurant. C'est-à-dire que quand tu as bien aimé un restaurant , tu vas en parler à un personne,
quand tu n'as pas aimé un restaurant, tu vas en parler à 10 personnes.
Donc si les youtubeurs demandent souvent des pouces en fins de vidéos, ils ne l'associent pas toujours à leur propre égo.
Même si, c'est vrai, je l'avoue, ça fait vraiment plaisir.
C'est aussi un bon moyen pour voir si la vidéo qu'on a faite, elle a plu ou pas, et si il faut qu'on continue dans cette direction.
C'est-à-dire, qu'on a pas beaucoup d'indicateurs sur YouTube.
Tu auras une vidéo de 50 000 vues, on va avoir 400 commentaires. Ce n'est pas assez pour être un bon indicateur.
Les pouces sont un bon indicateur.
Et après effectivement, plus il y a d’interaction, mieux les vidéos sont référencées.
Mais ça, j'ai envie de vous dire, vous le savez en fait depuis le départ. Ça c'est sûr et certain.
Non, c'est l'indicateur quand même qui prime, et effectivement le plaisir personnel de voir que ça vous a plu.
Mais je reviens quand même à tous ces trucs de vouloir passer en top commentaires, de vouloir avoir plus de like sur Facebook, d’être retwitté à mort sur Twitter...
En même temps sur quoi d'autre que sur Twitter d’être retwitté ? Je suis stupide.
C'est parce que les réseaux sociaux aussi ont augmenté, je vous l'ai dit il y a quelques secondes, le facteur de comparaison avec l'autre.
C'est-à-dire qu'on voit les photos passées des autres, les photos de vacances des autres... et on a envie de ça et en fait ça nous rend triste.
C'est assez terrible d'ailleurs.
Si on voit passer le poste de quelqu'un qui a beaucoup plus de like que ces propres postes, alors ça nous rend triste, ça nous rend un petit peu envieux.
Alors qu'on oublie que si ça se trouve, il y a une semaine c'était l'inverse.
C'est juste l'instant présent qui compte.
Il y a une psy qui a parlé pour ça de pulsions scopiques.
C'est vraiment intéressant.
Oui mais c'est qui la psy ?!
C'est Bénédicte Vidaillet. Achetez son livre si vous voulez le voir, ce n'est pas disponible en source sur Internet.
La pulsion scopique c'est une définition de l'envie suggérée par la vue.
C'est en voyant quelque chose que l'envie est la plus forte. Ce n'est pas forcément en la mentalisant ou en l'intellectualisant, c'est en voyant quelque chose qu'on a envie de ça.
La pulsion scopique.
Donc forcément, via l'écran, via les réseaux sociaux, la pulsion scopique, elle est au taquet.
Elle se réveille tout le temps !
Spinoza parlait des passions tristes, c'est exactement ce qui se passe avec certains top commentaires YouTube, avec les Facebook, les Twitter, les Insta...
Ils ont tendance à démultiplier les sentiments d'envie, de tristesse et de solitude.
Alors j'ai deux choses à vous dire à ce sujet.
La première chose que j'ai à vous dire, c'est que n'oubliez que ce n'est jamais la vraie vie.
Moi par exemple, ce que je publie sur Facebook, c'est que les trucs cools qui m'arrivent.
Je mets des jolis filtres, je vous fait des blagues, mais je ne dis pas quand ça ne va pas.
Et la plupart d'entre vous, vous faites pareil.
Donc forcément, ce n'est pas une comparaison de la vraie vie, qu'on fiat sur Facebook, sur Twitter, sur Intagram, sur les réseaux.
Ça, n'oubliez jamais ça, c'est très important.
Ce n'est pas un reflet, on donne juste un petit prisme, et c'est celui qu'on a envie de donner, qu'on maîtrise.
Et la deuxième chose, c'est toujours par rapport aux endorphines.
Les endorphines c'est pas mal en soit, au contraire c'est un super stimulant.
Prenez en conscience, maîtrisez le et vous allez pouvoir atteindre pleins d'objectifs.
Si j'ai quelque chose de très embêtant à faire, ce qui est parfois le cas et il y a des taches répétitives ou des choses que l'on a pas envie de faire.
Je ne me dis pas quand j'aurai terminé je vais me poser, et prendre un petit café, non, je cherche quelque chose de vraiment cool après, en terme de récompense.
Une vraie récompense, quelque chose de très bien, qui va me faire extrêmement plaisir à moi.
J'aime beaucoup courir, en l'occurrence ça peut être aller à la salle de sport durant une heure.
Je sais que c'est quelque chose que j'ai envie de faire quotidiennement, mais je n'irai pas si je n'ai pas fait ça.
Et alors là du coup, j'ai triple gratification, puisqu'en finissant la tache, forcément j'ai une sorte de satisfaction personnelle,
ensuite je vais là où j'ai envie d'aller, et comme je fais du sport, j'en ai encore un petit stock.
Mmh, qui fait du bien !
Un moyen sûr aussi de forcer son cerveau et à nous donner de l'endorphine, c'est de se donner des défis.
A chaque fois qu'on réalise un défi qu'on s'est donné, le cerveau, fait un petit open bar.
Et là vous comprenez, pourquoi j'ai lancé le Mental Vlog.
J'espère vous avoir fait bien prendre conscience de ça.
Puisque quand on comprend le mécanisme, on peut l’utiliser.
Et c'est toujours l’intérêt de comprendre les choses, si tu comprends le game, alors tu peux utiliser les règles à ton avantage pour être plus performant, ou pour être plus heureux, pour être plus tout ce que tu veux !
Et je me mets à vous tutoyer alors que je vous vouvoie. Ça n'a pas de sens.
J'espère donc que cette vidéo vous a plu.
Si elle vous a plu, vous pouvez faire la fête à mon cerveau à coups de...
Pah ! Pah ! Pah !
Vous pouvez également laisser un petit commentaire, je me fais un plaisir de les lire tous les jours, tout le temps.
Hier, Emmy, de la chaîne EmmyMakeUpPro a mis une vidéo sur sa chaîne.
Elle m'avait invité chez elle au mois d’août pour faire une vidéo. Elle l'a publiée hier.
Si vous voulez la regarder, foncez ! C'est en ligne, depuis hier 16H.
Et si ce n'est pas déjà fait, attention, parce que je sais qu'il y en a où c'est le cas... vous pouvez vous abonner avant de partir.
En attendant le Mental Vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an, du 1er janvier au 31 décembre.
Il doit en rester 85 je crois.
Rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !